alors en fait michel platini a déclaré
dans une interview que le tirage au sort
de la coupe du monde 1998 la fameuse
celle qu'on a gagné la seule voie là
avait donné lieu à des petits
arrangements il a même dit une petite
magouille c'est à dire qu'on avait fait
exprès de répartir la france et le
brésil dans deux poules tellement
éloignés que ces deux formations ne
pouvait pas s'affronter avant la finale
on va regarder et on en parle juste
après mais c'est chaud très discret sur
la luge c'est scandaleux c'est non reçus
scandaleux tu parles même moi qui n'aime
pas le foot nous sommes dans la soirée
du 12 juillet 1998 quand la foule
envahit les champs elysées en effet pour
la première fois de l'histoire la france
est championne du monde zinedine zidane
laurent blanc ou encore lilian thuram
entre dans la légende en battant le
brésil 3 à 0
par la suite l'équipe de france ne
renouvellera plus jamais cet exploit en
2002 l'échec en 2006 défaite sur un coup
de tête
quant à 2010 les bleus s'arrête en quart
alors que didier deschamps a annoncé
hier soir sa liste des mondialistes chez
gilles bouleau une autre légende du foot
allait provoquer un véritable ouragan
michel platini plus connu sous le surnom
de platoche coe président du comité
d'organisation de la coupe du monde 98
avoue avoir magouiller afin que l'équipe
d'aimé jacquet ne puisse pas rencontrer
le brésil avant la finale alors michel
catty n'y at-il vraiment favorisé
l'équipe de france 1998 avant même le
début de la compétition
les dés étaient ils pipés et surtout
est-ce que passe partout et de la
famille d'emmanuel petit autant de
questions auxquelles le détective rdr va
tenter de répondre ceci est une parodie
heures dans l'émission stade 2 qui sera
diffusé donc dimanche prochain
effectivement michel platini légendaire
numéro 10 de l'équipe de france a fait
cette confidence
comme quoi il ya eu quelques petites
magouilles on veut voir l'extrait dans
sa longueur et on parle juste après le
temps d'organiser chefs organisé le
calendrier calendrier il a fait petites
magouilles qui a signé ses premiers et
le brésil promis pouvait pas se
rencontrer avant la finale
pas mal oui c'est bien sûr ben oui on
est à la maison venus profiter des
choses
bon on va pas sans l'indépendance ils
organisent de la coupe du monde ça ne
peut pas faire quelques petites
magouilles mais andrew était embarrassé
l'avant alors j'ai de quoi il parle en
fait
alors d'abord les tirages au sort de
coupe du monde ou de grandes épreuves
il ya eu énormément de rumeurs on
appelait ça c'est devenu l'expression
boules chaudes bull froide et faire que
pour pas que votre équipe tombe sur un
adversaire trop redoutable il y avait à
l'époque ya longtemps des boules chaudes
et les boules froide comme ça vous
saviez qui était dans les boules ça
permettait d'avoir un tirage arranger ça
s'est passé comme dans motus exactement
ça s'est passé voilà alors là dans ce
cas précis parce qu'il y avait un
tableau dont le cas mais un tableau
était tête de série
ouais mémoire donc voilà donc on s'est
arrangé le pays organisateur l'était on
s'est arrangé c'est vrai que c'est un
arrangement
c'est vrai que c'est un procédé qui peut
paraître déloyale il faut savoir que
tous les pays organisateurs de chaque
coupe du monde s'arrange pour avoir un
nom
tableau on appelle ça un tableau s'avère
avoir des adversaires les moins
redoutable possible là attendez
magouille ou pas magouille gbagbo